just a quick question what are we
supposed to be doing as Selena Gomez
wraps up her 30th year she jokes she has
no clue what she's supposed to be doing
I'm constantly somebody that likes to
grow and feel like all right what could
I be better at what could I do better at
where where could my confidence be
stronger Sal posted this clip to tick
tock on Friday bringing the LOLs just a
quick question to anyone who's over 30
what are we supposed to be doing of
course the triple threat turned 30 last
July
[Music]
her B-day with her bestie Taylor Swift
posting this pic alongside the caption
30 nerdy and worthy she's been in my
life for so long
point so it's awesome just here because
we're both really busy and when we get
to like meet up it's really great and
while Selena pokes funded herself on
tick tock what are we supposed to be
doing I'm not good with change to be
honest she's crushing it IRL I'm ready
to do it you know I'm ready to go to the
next level with him Selena wrapped
filming on season three of only murders
in the building we hope everybody enjoys
it posting this pic in April with guest
star Meryl Streep calling the season
deliriously hilarious challenging and an
absolute dream
oh my God it's me
oh I'm sorry it's me isn't it crime and
murder yeah and murder mixed with kind
of an element of crime dead yes and
death permeates it's really funny
as for her love life well
on Thursday cell shared that clip to
tick tock shooting her shot during a
soccer game
I'm single
I'm just a little high maintenance
but I love you so much I think my advice
is to not be afraid Selena was most
recently spotted out in NYC with Zayn
Malik in March
before that she was linked to The
Chainsmokers Drew Taggart
the pair was spotted on a couple of
dates but ultimately cell set the record
straight on her Instagram story in
January when she clarified I'm single
well I think it's nice to have a little
bit something to myself well it looks
like Selena is still looking for the one
I'm single but in the meantime it's all
about self-love it's important just to
remain positive I'm at that age where I
feel like that's what matters is making
sure I'm healthy and people are happy
that I love